I'm really curious about your views about,
well,
what,
what postmodernism is.
First of all,
I know you've,
you've identified it with the,
with the general tricksters,
Derrida and Lakota and Sukkot and from coal in particular you've talked about,
but I'd like to know what you think about postmodernism and also why you think
it's been so attractive to people.
Well,
my explanation is that there is no authentic 1960s point of view in any of the
elite universities.
Okay.
But rather,
the most liberated minds of my generation were 1960 did not go onto graduate
school.
I witnessed this with my own eyes.
I saw genuine Marxist.
Okay.
At my college,
which was the State University of New York at Binghamton,
upstate New York Harbor College,
which had a huge cohort of very radical downstate New York Jews.
Okay.
Who in fact the Harper would,
we used to be called Berkeley East.
So I saw genuine,
passionate marks this with my own eyes.
They were not word choppers and they were not snide postmodernists right.
They were in your face aggressive.
They use the language of the people.
They had a populist and energy.
Okay.
They dressed working class.
They were non materialistic.
Hey,
these are people who lived by their own convictions.
They were against the graduate school.
So when I,
when I,
uh,
went on to graduate school and it became known that I was going to go to Yale,
I was confronted by a leader of the radicals on campus.
I'm in broad daylight in front of everyone who denounced me for is the new Grad
school is not where it's happening.
You don't,
you don't do that.
If you have to go to graduate school,
you should go to buffalo.
Now,
I had applied to these students as SUNY buffalo because the great leftest
critic,
Leslie Fiedler was there who had a huge impact on me.
He's part,
he created,
created identity politics,
but without it's present distortions,
right.
Uh,
and Norman Holland,
the psychoanalytic critic was there.
I would have a very happy to have gone on to Buffalo,
but I needed the library Yale.
So I continued on to,
yeah,
the word,
no radicals in the,
in the graduate schools,
right.
From 1968 to 72 when I was there.
Only one radical Todd Gitlin.
Okay.
Went on to have a career success.
The,
the actual radicals in the 1960s either when off dropped out of college and went
off to create communes or they were taking acid and destroyed their brains.
Now I have also written about that the destruction of the,
of the mines.
Okay.
Alpha,
the most talented members of my generation through Lsd,
it was going on all around me,
right towards what's happened is the actual legacy of the 60s got truncated.
The idea that these poststructuralism postmodernists are heirs of the 1960
[inaudible] revolution is an absolute crock.
Okay.
What they represent as Fuko shows,
shows Foucault said,
okay.
The biggest influence on his thinking was Samuel Beckett's waiting for Godot.
Okay.
Which wasn't post World War Two play written in Paris.
That was about the disillusionment and nihilism experienced.
After Hitler went through occupied France and all of Europe was in ruins.
It had nothing to do.
What's in when you were going to go has nothing to do with the authentic legacy
of the 1960s which was about genuine multiculturalism,
a movement toward India,
toward Hinduism.
I a transformation of consciousness through psychedelics,
which I did not take,
but which identify with totally through the music,
et cetera.
All right?
It was a turn toward the body.
It was a turn toward sensory experience.
Okay.
I'm not this,
this word shopping thing and it's like cynical removal from actual experience.
Right.
That French import.
Okay.
Came in.
It should,
the graduate schools,
it did not affect any genuine 1960s person,
the real 19 six,
his revolution was about young.
It was about a way of seeing the cosmos in mythological terms.
Right.
And the union contribution went on into the new age movement of the 1970s.
Aside from the universities.
So who took over the universities were these careerists I saw them with my own
eyes.
I saw what happened.
I saw I was at Yale when dairy dye was being shipped over and to,
to,
to address the,
uh,
you know,
the,
the students or Grad students and the faculty and I,
and I said to a fellow student after hearing one of these guys speak,
it wasn't dairy died,
it was a,
it wasn't another one of the theorists.
I said,
they are like high priests murmuring to each other.
Uh,
this,
this was an elitist form from the start.
Okay.
It was not progressive.
It was knocked revolutionary.
It was reactionary.
It was a desperate attempt to hold on to what had happened before the 1960s
sensory revolution.
Nope.
Well,
this postmodernist thing.
Okay.
This trashing,
okay.
Of,
of the text.
This is this encouragement.
Okay.
Have I superior and destructive attitude toward the work of art we're going
through.
It's okay.
Primly with red pen in hand.
Finding all the evidence of sexism.
Check racism,
check homophobia.
Check.
That is not the impact.
Thick emotional.
Okay.
Sensory based.
A revolution of the 1960s.
I,
I am sick and tired of these people claiming any kind of mantle from the 1960s
they're frauds.
These people are,
what happened in the 1970s was a collapse of the job market in academe.
Right?
All of a sudden jobs were scarce and this thing was there.
The new and improved and shiny thing.
Okay.
To be a theorist,
people seized on it.
Okay.
It was institutionalized.
Right.
And I,
it's an enormous betrayal of the 1960 [inaudible].